vous
[Musique]
ok je joue à quitte ou double les knicks
vont se réveiller après ce temps mort
mélo va marquer à trois points depuis la
ligne de fond promis pasqua well as it
here
je suis un homme libre à toi de jouer
maintenant d'accord 3 devrait
normalement avoir une promotion pour
passer manager sait pas comment c'est
passé l'entraînement super qu'est ce que
vous faites
or on est en train de fêter crocs nouvel
ordre ça fait longtemps qu'on sait pas
parler j'ai appris pour ton gosse waouh
j'ai eu un peu de chance récemment
voulez vous en faire profiter t'es pas
curieux de savoir combien j'ai gagné
combien dit bill et si tu avais perdu
alors je n'aime pas mêler les étudiants
à cela mais nous n'avons pas encore reçu
le chèque pour les frais de scolarité du
second semestre
j'ai pas réussi à joindre vos parents
j'ai pas voulu angoissé maman je sais
qu'ils bossent non-stop toute la semaine
professeur j'allais pouvoir justement
j'ai su que j'avais gagné avec les
rangers hier soir le plan c'était de
rembourser une partie de mes tête tu
pensais pas qu'on serait au courant 1
c'est pas possible qu'il ne puisse pas
gagner sur lui il est parti va écoute je
crois que j'ai quelque chose de sûr
quelque chose de fiable
je sais pour les frais de scolarité tu
crois que je me sens pas si mal comme ça
combien tu dois ça te regarde pas va te
faire [ __ ]
combien tu dois
j'aurais dû protéger ton fils toi ouais
tout ira bien
[Musique]
donc moi je suis le tireur tu peux pas
m'arrêter
1 je vais pulvériser